Jenna Orga will not be returning for
Scream 7 if it doesn't have anything to
do with the Melissa Barrera drama then
what's going on and what does it mean
for the fate of the movie earlier this
week it was reported that Melissa
Barrera would not be returning for the
currently entitled seventh scream film
Barrera who plays Sam Carpenter in the
franchise was fired by spy glass media
over social media post relating to the
ongoing Israeli Palestinian conflict
being famous isn't all it's cracked up
to be
barrera's dismissal from the highly
anticipated Scream 7 has proven to be
controversial and left fans of the long
running slasher series une easy about
the franchise's future now deadline
reports that Orga who stars as Tara
Carpenter will also not be returning to
apprise her role the outlet notes that
Orga who has emerged as one of
Hollywood's most in demand talents since
her 2022 scream debut is leaving the
franchise to film Wednesday season 2
Ora's decision reportedly has nothing to
do with Barrera firing her choice to
call it curtains on screen was made
months ago according to the Hollywood
Reporter though it hasn't escaped many
that the bombshell news comes in the
wake of yesterday's controversial move
Scream 7 is still in early production in
fact a deadline says a script isn't even
ready yet and Orga has big plans
occupying her schedule the ex-actress is
heading to irland in April to start
filming Wednesday season 2 and needs to
wrap up the decades in the making Beetle
Juice 2 which was forced to pause
production to the 2023 s after a strike
with Orga and Barrera out of the picture
it's unclear what a scream seven would
look like after all the franchise made
it pretty darn clear with 2023 Scream 6
that the carpenter sisters would be at
the heart of the series going forward
Sam
coming it's sort of surprising that the
scream franchise has found itself in
this position considering just how
prominent the series has been in recent
years after remaining dormant for over
over a decade directors Matt battinelli
opin and Tyler Gillette revived the
slasher series of 2022 scream which saw
the carpenter sisters teaming up with
old guards Sydney Prescott and Gail
weathers to protect the town of
woodsborough from a new ghost face the
film emerged as a substantial success
grossing over $138 million worldwide and
proving that the series could be
relevant to gen Z Paramount Pictures and
spy glass quickly produced a sequel
releasing Scream Six to even greater
critical and financial Acclaim earlier
this year the scream franchise hasn't
even peaked yet but it seems as if its
wings are being cut off happy death day
series director Christopher Landon was
roped in earlier this year to direct the
upcoming Scream 7 but it's unclear when
production on the 7th outing will start
for Orga however this is a major
strategic move the actress has turned
into a superstar since scream and it
makes sense that she wants to double
down on Wednesday the Netflix series
that turned her into an overnight horror
icon and an Emmy nominee while the
scream franchise has always been great
to her they were never really her
projects to begin with unlike Wednesday
which has clearly a showcase for her
talents as a lead
star